[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an meiner Seite ist wieder
Norbert Lehmann für den Sport einen
schönen guten Abend die Polizei
durchsuchte heute Wohnungen der
sogenannten letzten Generation
bundesweite Razzia gegen klimakleber die
Staatsanwaltschaft München spricht von
einer kriminellen Organisation
trotz Freispruchs wieder vor Gericht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht verhandelt über
umstrittene Gesetzesreform
und umstrittener Milliarden Deal für die
Fußball-Bundesliga geplatzt auch viele
Fans waren gegen den Einstieg eines
sponsers bei der DFL
[Musik]
die groß angelegte Razzia gegen die
sogenannte letzte Generation zeige dass
der Rechtsstaat sich nicht auf der Nase
herumtanzen lässt das sagt die
bundesinnenministerin Greenpeace und
andere Klimaschützer nennen das Vorgehen
völlig unverhältnismäßig
170 Polizisten durchsuchten bundesweit
Wohnungen und Geschäftsräume die
Internetseite der letzten Generation
wurde vom Netz genommen der Vorwurf
Bildung und Unterstützung einer
kriminellen Vereinigung
zeitgleich sind Beamte heute Morgen wie
hier in Berlin in mehreren Bundesländern
angerückt um 15 Objekte von Mitgliedern
der sogenannten letzten Generation zu
durchsuchen Hintergrund die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München
ermittelt gegen 7 klimaaktivisten wegen
der Bildung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung den Beschuldigten wird
konkret unter anderem vorgeworfen eine
Spendenaktion organisiert beworben und
durchgesetzt zu haben um Geldern
einzuwerten um quasi weitere Straftaten
der letzten Generation zu finanzieren
nach dem bisherigen Erkenntnissen hat
man auf diese Weise 1,4 Millionen Euro
gesammelt seit rund einem Jahr kleben
sich klimaaktivisten der letzten
Generation bundesweit wie heute wieder
auf dem Berliner Ring an Autos oder auf
Straßenfest oder beschmieren Fassaden
mit Farbe wie gestern die Berliner
SPD-Zentrale um auf ihre Forderungen
aufmerksam zu machen im Fokus der
Ermittler stehen jetzt unter anderem
zwei Aktivisten die letztes Jahr
versucht haben sollen die Öl Pipeline
Triest Ingolstadt zu sabotieren die
Bayern zentral versorgt
legitimer Protest endet immer dort wo
Straftaten begangen werden und andere in
ihren Rechten verletzt werden die
Reaktion der letzten Generation auf die
heutigen Hausdurchsuchungen sie machen
uns Angst aber wir dürfen nicht in
dieser Angst verharren
die Bundesregierung fährt uns gerade
sehenden Auges in eine klima-hölle mit
ihren umstrittenen Aktionen will die
letzte Generation auf die katastrophalen
Folgen der erderhitzung aufmerksam
machen die Bewegung sei zwar provokant
und konfrontativ nicht aber als radikal
zu bezeichnen so protestforscher sie
verzichtet auf Gewalt vor allem Gewalt
gegen Personen und man muss dazu sagen
ihre Forderungen sind wirklich nicht
sehr radikal sondern bewegen sich in
einem doch eher moderaten Spektrum wenn
wir daran denken dass es um Tempolimits
und bürgerräte hier gibt als zentrale
Forderung aus Protest gegen die heutigen
Razzien gingen am Nachmittag in Berlin
Unterstützer der letzten Generation auf
die Straße in den nächsten Tagen soll es
auch in Leipzig und München
Demonstrationen geben
unsere Rechtsexpertin sarattacke ist bei
mir Sarah kriminelle Vereinigung da
denkt man zuerst an Mafia Terror
Geldwäsche Menschenhandel erfüllt die
letzte Generation die Kriterien einer
solchen kriminellen Vereinigung also
klar ist Mitglieder der letzten
Generation begehen immer wieder
Straftaten bei den Straßenblockaden bei
dem festklebenden strafbare Nötigung das
haben Gericht auch immer wieder so
entschieden aber um als kriminelle
Vereinigung eingestuft zu werden bedarf
ist mehr man muss ihn nachweisen dass
sie sich mit dem Ziel
zusammengeschlossen haben Straftaten zu
begehen kann man schon Fragezeichen
machen und man muss ihn nachweisen dass
die Straftaten die sie begehen erheblich
sind kann man auch in Frage stellen
machen das heißt es ist alles andere als
entschieden ob die letzte Generation
eine kriminelle Vereinigung ist und es
ist unter Juristen äußerst umstritten
was bedeutet das denn für eine
Organisation wenn sie als kriminell
eingestuft wird das hat weitreichende
Folgen allein der vorwurfende kriminelle
Vereinigung zu sein bedeutet dass
Ermittler telefonüber zu machen können
dass sie durchsuchen können wie heute
auch geschehen um zu schauen wie
finanziert sich die Organisation und
auch kontenbeschlagnahmen können
Internetseiten sperren können das heißt
Ermittler haben durch diese Einstufung
weitreichende Möglichkeiten und außerdem
wirkt natürlich so eine Einstufung
abschrecken denn wer so eine Verein und
der kriminelle Vereinigung unterstützt
macht sich unter Umständen sogar durchs
bloße Spenden oder natürlich auch durchs
mitmachen mit strafbar wichtige
Informationen vielen Dank sarattacke
sind die klimaaktivisten zurecht im
Visier der Behörden darüber streiten
zwei Juristen bei ZDF heute live um
19.30 in der ZDF heute App und auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen
kaum ein Thema erhitzt die politischen
Gemüte in Berlin so wie das sogenannte
heizungsgesetz neben den inhaltlichen
Details geht es dabei besonders um den
grundsätzlichen Streit in der
Ampelkoalition eine Steilvorlage für die
Opposition die alle parlamentarischen
Mittel auffährt und den zuständigen
Minister Habeck im Visier behält
Patricia Wiedemeier berichtet
ein sichtlich genervter Robert Habeck
heute Nachmittag im Bundestag nach
zweistündiger Befragung im Wirtschafts-
und klimaausschuss jetzt auch noch
aktuelle Stunde zum Gebäude
Energiegesetz da brauchte schon mal
Rückendeckung aus der eigenen Fraktion
offen sprechen in diesen Zeiten aber
anscheinend kaum noch möglich von der
Opposition heftige Kritik am Streit in
der Ampel Stress Selbstbeschäftigung
Chaos Blockade auf dem Weg in die
Regierungsunfähigkeit das ist der
Zustand der Koalition das Desaster und
das heizungsgesetz macht das Ganze
Unvermögen dieser Bundesregierung
sichtbar sie haben ihren Namen wirklich
nicht im Griff eins ist doch klar die
wärmewende ist nicht machbar denn wir
haben nicht genügend Wärmepumpen wir
haben nicht genügend Handwerker wir
haben nicht genügend Strom das Sehen
Grüne und SPD natürlich ganz anders sie
verteidigen die Pläne und kritisieren
ihrerseits die Union wo sind denn bitte
die Vorschläge hier das Thema Wärme von
der CDU zu beantworten liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
wo ist ein Vorschlag das Gesetz muss
beraten werden muss hier beraten werden
das ist das da wo es hingehört das ist
Aufgabe von uns Parlamentariern lassen
Sie uns die Blockade an der Stelle
auflösen gemeint war natürlich die FDP
sie schlug heute gemäßigtere Töne an es
ist doch klar es braucht eine Novelle
des Gebäude Energiegesetzes und es ist
auch klar so wie das aus der Regierung
gekommen ist wird das nicht durch dieses
Parlament gehen es braucht eine
Novellierung klar ist am heutigen Tage
allerdings gar nichts weder der Inhalt
des Gesetzes noch wann ist denn wirklich
im Bundestag beraten wird
der Bundeskanzler war heute beim
Deutschen Städtetag dort fordern die
Kommunen von Bund und Ländern stärker
einbezogen zu werden bei Klimaschutz und
Energiewende das gingen nicht von oben
nach unten sondern nur gemeinsam und
ausgerichtet am tatsächlichen Bedarf der
Städte sagt städtetagspräsident Markus
lebe wie das gelingen kann zeigt dort
die Farbe am Beispiel Bottrop
Solarpaneele überall mitten im
Kohlenpott Bottrop ist die NRW Stadt mit
den meisten Photovoltaikanlagen pro Kopf
und seit langem klimaforbild wir haben
tatsächlich in zehn Jahren 50 Prozent
unserer co2-mission einsparen können wir
haben dazu eine Blaupause geschrieben
die man auch ganz gut auf andere Städte
übertragen kann
Bottrop mit Zeche grau das war einmal
seit 2010 arbeitet die Stadt daran Grün
zu werden wohnen Verkehr Freizeit zum
Beispiel mit dem sogenannten energieplus
Mehrfamilienhaus hier wird sogar mehr
Energie erzeugt als verbraucht der
Keller voller Technik Wärmepumpe
Lüftungssystem hier wohnte sich gut
sagen Mieter
sehr schön bequem
auch wegen dem Strom sparen und
Energiesparhaus das merkt man auch also
es ist echt vorteilhaft in Bottrop
beziehen Sie die Menschen ein bei der
Energiewende tausendfach gab es
kostenlose Energieberatung und Zuschüsse
bei Modernisierung einer volksrezept
also nicht von oben wie Berlin immer
versucht den Leuten was zu obstruieren
sondern nein die Menschen zu befragen
wie kriegen wir denn deine Bude
klimagerecht umgebaut mit deinem
Portemonnaie so dass du auch etwas davon
hast bis 2035 will Bottrop nun
klimaneutral werden und dabei weiter
andere Städte beraten die genauso grün
werden wollen
nach der Bürgerschaftswahl in Bremen
gibt es jetzt Klarheit wie das ZDF
erfuhr strebt Bürgermeister Andreas
bovenschulte mit seiner SPD erneut ein
Bündnis mit den Grünen und der
Linkspartei an auch eine Koalition mit
der zweitstärksten Kraft der CDU wäre
möglich gewesen
seit 15 Monaten herrscht Krieg in der
Ukraine dabei entscheiden häufig
Informationen überleben und Tod doch oft
gibt es weder Handys noch Strom oder
Internet
südöstlich von saporicia in orichif
lässt sich eine Journalistin nicht
abschrecken sie verteilt Zeitungen im
Frontgebiet ganz klassisch schwarz auf
weiß Tim Krüger berichtet
sie sieht aus wie eine kriegsreporterin
dabei ist Swetlana kapenko
lokaljournalistin aber sie ist mit dem
Notdienst auf dem Weg in die zum Teil
heftig zerstörten Orte an der Front
zusammen mit anderen Hilfsgütern liefert
sie ihre Zeitung aus und vor allem die
älteren Menschen mit Informationen zu
versorgen beim Verteilen auf einmal
Raketen Lärm Svetlana bringt sich in
Sicherheit sie ist hier aufgewachsen
kennt die Menschen
wenn ich darüber nachdenke kommen ich
habe sie schon lange nicht mehr gesehen
seit über einem Jahr
denn die Zeitung lässt sie auf sicherem
Terrain 60 km von der Front produzieren
ein Jahr lang konnte sie wegen des
Krieges nicht erscheinen seit April gibt
es sie wenigstens wieder monatlich
das wichtigste ist doch zu wissen was
passiert wir wissen gar nichts es gibt
kein Radio kein Fernsehen kein Licht
seit einem Jahr
so leben wir hier früher
die Menschen sind vom raketenterror
gezeichnet oft fließend Tränen viele
haben ihre Häuser verloren sie hoffen
auf die ukrainische Gegenoffensive die
hier in der Gegend beginnen könnte
nachmittags wird es immer heftig
generell ist die Lage sehr angespannt
jeden Tag gibt es Beschuss Tag und Nacht
es wird Lana kapenko zeigt uns Ihr altes
Redaktionsgebäude auch hier sind die
Fenster durch Raketenbeschuss
zersplittert aber eines Tages will sie
alles wieder aufbauen
ich bin mir sicher dass es so kommt und
dann wird alles gut sein wir kommen
zurück und unsere Zeitung wird wieder
hier sein und dann wird die Zeit und
nicht wie jetzt nur als Sonderausgabe
erscheinen sagt sie sondern wie früher
zweimal pro Woche
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht geht es
seit heute um eine grundsätzliche Frage
muss ein Freispruch in einem Mordprozess
ein Freispruch bleiben oder darf jemand
für das selbe Verbrechen noch mal
angeklagt werden wenn es neue Beweise
gibt der Bundestag hatte die Regeln
dafür gelockert und damit viele Bedenken
ausgelöst jetzt ist Karlsruhe am Zug
Sarah kacke
sie wurde vergewaltigt und erstochen
1981 Friederike von Müllmann damals 17
Jahre Schülerin er ist mit H der
mutmaßliche Täter wird damals aus Mangel
an Beweisen freigesprochen doch 31 Jahre
später zeigt eine moderne DNA-Analyse
dass er wohl doch der Mörder ist erst
ein neues Gesetz ermöglicht es dann dass
der mutmaßliche Mörder erneut angeklagt
wird denn eigentlich gilt nach dem
Grundgesetz das Verbot der
Doppelbestrafung
sein ganz wichtiges rechtsstaatliches
Schutzinstrument wenn man einmal
freigesprochen wurde darf man sich
darauf verlassen dass diese Rechtskraft
für die Juristen sagen hält und dass der
Staat einen dann in Zukunft in Ruhe
lässt das neue Gesetz aber sieht vor
dass jemand der ein schwerstes
Verbrechen begangen hat das nicht
verjährt wie Mord oder Völkermord wenn
neue Tatsachen und Beweismittel
beigebracht werden auch erneut vor
Gericht gestellt werden kann ob das
zulässig ist prüft jetzt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht
das niemand wegen derselben Straftat
mehrmals bestraft werden darf anders
sieht es der Anwalt der Familie Müllmann
er ist vom Gesetz überzeugt das Gesetz
ist verfassungsgemäß weil es nur die
Delikte betrifft die nicht verjähren
können
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht stehen
die Grundsätze Gerechtigkeit dass eine
Tat auch bestraft wird gegen
Rechtssicherheit also das Recht des
einmal Freigesprochenen in Ruhe gelassen
zu werden beide sind im Grundgesetz
verankert beide wiegen schwer wie die
Richterinnen und Richter entscheiden
erfahren wir in einigen Monaten
eine Nachricht die vor allem die rund
55.000 Ärzte und Ärztinnen kommunaler
Kliniken interessieren dürfte sie
bekommen mehr Lohn und zwar 8,8 Prozent
plus 2500 Euro Inflationsausgleich
darauf haben sich der Marburger Bund und
die Vereinigung der kommunalen
Arbeitgeberverbände geeinigt
die Europäische Zentralbank feiert
Jubiläum seit 25 Jahren ist sie eine der
mächtigsten
Finanzinstitutionen der Welt zur Stunde
beginnt der Festakt in Frankfurt es ist
ein Jubiläum in schwierigen Zeiten
angesichts der hohen Inflation am 1 Juni
1998 hatte die EZB ihre Arbeit
aufgenommen
2002 gab es dann die neue Währung den
Euro für das Portemonnaie heute ist der
Euro im 20 EU-Staaten offizielles
Zahlungsmittel für 346
in Italien gilt heute Staatstrauer bei
der schweren Flutkatastrophe letzte
Woche kamen 15 Menschen ums Leben
in weiten Teilen der Emilia Romagna
herrscht immer noch Ausnahmezustand noch
ist das Wasser nicht ganz weg
zehntausende mussten ihre Häuser und
Wohnungen verlassen das Aufräumen geht
weiter in den Straßen türmt sich Dreck
und Hausrat die Schäden gehen in die
Milliarden besonders betroffen sind auch
die Landwirte Andreas Postel
die Fluten haben von seiner Kiwi
Plantage bei fancer wenig übrig gelassen
was der macht Zeno nicht mitgerissen hat
erstickt unter dem Matsch der in der
Sonne Brett hart wird Obstbauer remoland
Sony ist verzweifelt
ich hatte hier schon mit der Ernte
begonnen jetzt muss ich drei Jahre
warten bis ich ernten kann und dabei
natürlich wieder ganz von vorne anfangen
und das ganze Geld ausgeben um die
Felder neu anzulegen
Obstanbau ist aufwendig seine Kiwi
benötigen Rankhilfen und
Bewässerungssysteme von den verheerenden
Überschwemmungen sind laut
landwirtschaftsverband collieretti
allein in der Provinz Ravenna 5000
Bauernhöfe betroffen ca 50.000
Arbeitsplätze hängen davon ab das Obst
der Region wird normalerweise nach ganz
Europa exportiert der Ernteausfall ist
enorm
wir sprechen schon jetzt von einem
Warenverlust im Wert von anderthalb
Milliarden Euro die Wirtschaft eines
ganzen Gebietes droht in eine Krise zu
geraten
beim Besuch im Katastrophengebiet
verspricht Italiens Regierungschefin
Georgia Meloni schnelle Hilfe für die
Emilia Romania das Regierungskabinett in
Rom beschließt ein Milliardenpaket
ich kann sagen dass es in der Situation
in der sich Italien befindet nicht
einfach ist zwei Milliarden Euro in
wenigen Tagen aufzutreiben
technische Hilfe kommt aus Frankreich
und vom THW in Deutschland und morgen
wird eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula
von der Leyen ins Katastrophengebiet
Reisen es wird erwartet dass sie nicht
mit leeren Händen kommt
jetzt zum Sport da ging es bei der
Fußball-Bundesliga heute um viel Geld
Norbert ja und mindestens zwei
Milliarden Euro diese Summe erhoffte
sich jedenfalls die Deutsche Fußball
Liga durch den Einstieg eines privaten
Investors ein Projekt das vor allem in
der Fanszene auf Widerstand steht und
heute auch nicht der vaterliche Mehrheit
bei den 36 Bundesligaverein fand
die fußball-bosse sie wirkten ein
bisschen ernüchtert nicht bereit das
überraschende Abstimmungsergebnis zu
kommentieren es fehlten vier Jahr
Stimmen zur notwendigen zwei
drittelmehrheit 5 der 36 Profivereine
hatten sich der Stimme enthalten Projekt
gestoppt mit jedem Jahr das vergeht und
mit jeder
sozusagen Investition die andere liegen
tätigen wird das für uns immer
schwieriger und das muss uns eigentlich
klar sein der Widerstand kam vornehmlich
von kleineren Clubs die Fans fürchteten
unzulässige Einflussnahme des Geldgebers
auf Spielpläne dazu kommt leider noch
dass die Geld als Investor das ja sehr
sehr ungleich verteilt werden sollen die
die schon viel haben bekommen viel die
kleinen bekommen möglichst wenig das
zementiert aktuelle Verhältnisse und
verhinderten fernbettbewerb in punkto
Vermarktung wird der Rückstand zu
anderen liegen nun vermutlich nicht
geringer was den sportlichen Erfolg
angeht könnte sich die Lücke ebenso
vergrößern
ja Michael Krämer in Frankfurt was
bedeutet das jetzt für den Deutschen
Fußballern
ja zumindest aus Sicht der deutschen
Fußball Liga ist das heutige
Abstimmungsergebnis ein herberrückschlag
für die Bemühungen den Anschluss zu
halten an die europäischen top liegen
wie die englische Premier League oder
die spanische primäre Division wir haben
das gehört Oliver lecki einer der beiden
Interims Geschäftsführer der DFL sagte
bei uns am Mikrofon die Liga gehe keinen
leichten Zeiten entgegen ob man diese
Dramatik teilen muss sei mal
dahingestellt fest steht an der
Ausgangslage hat sich laut DFL nichts
verändert die Liga braucht dringend
frisches Kapital ein Investorenmodell
kommt hierfür jetzt nicht mehr in Frage
man muss sich andere alternative
Methoden suchen um frisches Geld zu
beschaffen oder man findet andere
kreative Ansätze um langfristig die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu stellen vielen
Dank für diese Einschätzung Michael
Krämer
ja gute Nachricht für den BVB Mats
Hummels bleibt drei Tage vor dem
Bundesliga Meisterschaft Showdown
einigten sich der Verein und sein
Abwehrchef auf eine Vertragsverlängerung
um ein Jahr Hummels hatte bereits
zweimal mit dem BVB den Titel geholt
ja aller guten Dinge sind drei werden
sich jetzt zumindest die BVB-Fans sagen
mit Blick auf den Samstag genau wir
werden sehen zum Schluss noch was
tierisch schönes das sind Sissi und
Nepomuk zwei junge Bartgeier die noch
nicht fliegen können aber groß genug
sind für das Leben in Freiheit ihr neues
Zuhause die bayerischen Berge wenn alles
glatt läuft schweben die beiden bald
über den Alpen es ist die dritte
Auswilderung von Bartgeiern im
Nationalpark Berchtesgaden so soll ihre
Art hier wieder heimisch werden
sie unten Nepomuk fehlen noch die
Lottozahlen sie lauten 1 6 7 9 16 43 und
die Superzahl 5 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite
morgen bleibt es meist trocken die
Details zum Weltall hat gleich östen
terli das heute journal gegen 20:11 Uhr
mit Maria Slomka Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend alles Gute und bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter auf der Ostseite
des Hochs auf dem Atlantik schmuggelt
sich hier diese Kaltfront rein nach
Deutschland und bringt einige Wolken es
wird aber kein Regen geben Regen gibt es
am Mittelmeer vor allem Richtung Spanien
mit diesem T4 das sorgt dann morgen auch
am Alpenrand für einige Schauer in der
Nacht regnet es ganz im Süden sonst
klartis in der Mitte teilweise auf von
Norden kommen kompaktere Wolken rein die
Temperaturen gehen zurück auf 3 Grad im
Vogtland oder im hessischen Bergland
milder Richtung Nordsee bei 10 Grad und
Morgen zunächst einmal im Süden trocken
und dann gibt's hier ein paar Schauer
mit dem abziehenden tief quasi ansonsten
aber in der Mitte Sonnenschein und von
Norden her kommt mit der Kaltfront
durchaus Bewölkung auf das bei höchsten
Temperaturen bis 24 Grad im Südosten 23
Grad im Rhein-Main-Gebiet nur 13 an der
Nordsee die nächsten Tage geht es
überwiegend trocken weiter am Freitag im
Norden kühler als sonst 14 bis 24 Grad
und am Wochenende wird es allmählich
wärmer und damit ein schöner Abend